I am absolutely 100 percent fluent in
Tagalog after just one week and that's
no lie.
Well actually
it is,
but you don't.
Hi Guys,
this is Paul.
Last week I posted a video telling you
about my intention to study together and
the question is did I actually follow
through,
did actually study it and follow the
plan that I had told you about or did I
sit around watching TV and drinking some
coke and eating chips and whatever
instead of studying,
that's the question.
So I'd like to show you a bit of my
week,
what I did and then show you the end
result,
which is some of what I learned during
that week.
So have a look and see what you think.
All right,
let me later.
Alright,
cool.
I know a Nigga got a whole Mckee a Patel
word that Hill India whole mesh are Dong
modern young monk Tagalog pedal a into
the content essentially.
Lingo Belang a whole nother,
either tagalog,
Tagalog,
that hill,
a mandala.
So Home Filipinas,
uh,
is our whole Canadian bet or a NASA on a
home.
I on a knuckle toe to toe alcohol.
None Inglis a mega diversity debt at
Gusto Kong and Trabaho Hoco sound
diversey dead good.
Stockholm because Tacoma Ebt,
Bang,
lingua my gluck being a good gusto.
Coding a Mug.
Busta non liberal at Maga.
None.
I'm mad on my own to comb Gumala and non
video at youtube at a similar blog at Sa
sa liberal icon.
A gusto coding.
Mccullough Kabocha a customer on Kai.
He began call India home.
Now you've got a that he'll uh,
that he,
that he.
He's not go one.
Okay.
Meghan.
Done.
Adot.
Is that your.